aaron sivali is going to be the starter
for the indians today again we told you
about his first start only allowed the
two hits the first time through they
were two for eight after that the next
15 batters they were over 13 and he
walked a couple so he's ready to go
here's the 2-1 this one stays fair and
finds a hole
a lead-off single for robbie grossman
willie castro the former indian two for
four last night here's the pitch and
it's swung on bank sharply to third
backhanded by ramirez goes to second one
relay to first by the shortstop jimenez
double play the second baseman hernandez
had no chance to get to second
and when's the last time you saw
a five
six three double play the 2-2 check
swing did he go around you darn right he
did and so candelario strengths out
tigers pitcher tarek school good start
to five and a third in his first start
at comerica got a no decision great
stuff really been coming that'll bring
up cesar hernandez he's hitless in his
last 15 advance and he ropes one to
center field and a diving attempt by
reyes he won't get it on his way to
second with a one out double is cesar
hernandez
that's his second double of the year in
his first since his first at back
so the indians have runners at first and
second one out in this scoreless first
inning eddie rosario here's the one two
swung out and missed
big pitch big out for terrex scuba
there's a little better slider now front
middle ray is at the plate the one-owner
reyes
driven to center field and victor reyes
is there
threat in the first inning for the
indians they do not score on this
saturday evening
the 3-2
strike three called he back-doored him
and savala gets mazara looking second
out
second strikeout and now the switch
hitting second baseman nico goodram and
the 1-1
hit in the air to left
back goes eddie rosario on to the track
and makes the grab just shy of the wall
the tigers go one two three
the payoff to chang
inside he walked him so chang draws the
second free ride
the indians have a one out base runner
and inning number two
no score for catcher roberto perez
banning 214 with a homer two ribbies
swung on hammered high
deep to left center way out of here
a towering blast
into the bleachers in left center and
perez has his second home run
and the indians have a two-nothing lead
well i'll tell you another two run homer
for the indians and there it is a
fastball center cut down the middle
watch it boy he put a nice swing on that
one got the hands through some extension
was out and he knew it he was just
sitting there watching it he knew it was
going to make the bleachers easily
now akil badu right got him
punched him out with that cutter on the
outside corner third strikeout for
savali
here comes that cutter on the outside
edge to the left-hander another good
pitch that's almost like that back door
two seamer for her righty against uh
right hand hitters i thought you're down
at the corner
no that was friday night
high pop
eddie rosario
makes the catch
one two three go to the tigers
tarek
the heart throwing southpaw to face two
three and four in the indians lineup and
the pits swung in and ripped into deep
black field gone
and the indians have their second home
run in as many innings
cesar hernandez
busting out of the slump in a big way a
double to right center and a laser to
left
his first home run and the indians now
lead it three to nothing
and this lineup
takes on a whole different look once
cesar hernandez
starts to swing it the way he did a year
ago
tigers really are in pretty good shape
in terms of their bullpen even though
they had to scratch the starter last
night three two swinging a miss
that's a really good slider down and in
reya's got a head 3-0 and a great bounce
back
by tariq skubal
fourth inning three nothing cleveland
leads it top of the order for detroit
robbie grossman
swinging a miss strikes him out that's
four k's for savali he's fanned one in
every inning so far here's the pitch to
candelario he swings lines it to first
caught by chang
and savali won't have a much more easy
inning than the fourth yu chang walked
and scored in the second inning few and
far between smokes this one down into
the corner
on his way to second is chang and he's
in with a stand-up double
his second two bagger on the season
and the indians have something brewing
here in the fourth inning two men aboard
with two outs for luplow
there's a ball driven to deep center
back is reyes he's looking up it is gone
he cleared the 19-foot wall in center
field and jordan luplow
with a big blast a three-run shot with
two down here in the fourth to make it
six nothing cleveland boy i'll tell you
what these guys are hitting homers and
this one looks like it might be a cut
fastball
and that's out over the plate and i mean
straight away central the tigers still
have not had it at bat with a runner in
scoring position in this series
and one hopper
jimenez goes to ramirez onto chang
inning over derrick school's night is
over alex lang makes his major league
debut this is the
trade from
the cubs
from july of 2019 for nick castellanos
he was a cubs first round pick in 2017
oh it worked
save that baseball
first strikeout of that young man's
major league career and it's against a
thumper too
nasty pitch in the dirt got him swinging
two down for the catcher grayson griner
now the payoff pitch
swing and a miss went upstairs scott
greiner with the hard stuff
and aaron somali continues to dominate
five strikeouts and six shutout innings
of two hit baseball the indians have
missed first and second two down leading
six nothing
top of the order and jordan luplow
drilled a deep left
but due says bye-bye
that's a home run they're saying no
that i think that ball went over the
yellow line and muddy hit a railing
they're going to take a look let's take
it watch it he's got to hit one of those
railings and that would be his second uh
three run homer the ball game look at
the big grayish man look at him look at
he wants that three run digger oh my wow
i can't believe that
so jordan luplow will have to settle for
a two out two run double and the indians
now lead this ball game eight to nothing
savali the last three innings the pitch
count
very impressive
slams one to right center field and that
ball is off the top of the wall and gone
into the bullpen and robbie grossman has
his first homer as a tiger
there's a good aggressive swing
pitches right over the heart boom
[Applause]
yeah but it doesn't scare him anymore
that's great
swung on a weak chopper to third
shoulder high hop handled ramirez throws
out cabrera and 79 pitches is all
it has taken aaron savali to get through
seven and the indians
leading eight to one reyes drives one
again deep right field gone
and reyes hits the indians fourth home
run tonight
and the indians playing home run derby
at the expense of the tiger pitching
staff and now lead it nine to one here
in the seventh
[Applause]
cesare throws him out two away
here comes tito and we're going to get a
pitching change and aaron sivali got to
the 90 pitch mark
with the tribe's longest start of the
season as he goes seven and two thirds
innings
shift to the right side
the one-two swung on this has hit a ton
deep right center field this is gone
number five for the indians
a two-run home run to right-center for
andre simenes
his first home run
and first rbis as an indian it's 11-1
cleveland
demanding this pitch
the 2-2
pounded to deep right field and jamer
candelario has gone yard
a two-run blast for his first homer of
the season
here's the one-two
he pretty well to left but rosario
backpedaling
makes the catch
and the indians win again
they've won three straight
[Applause]